So just so you remember that I will have more fee to cover one to 9, you know, for the coming, you know, like Monday, which is 27th and 28th. And just to confirm with you, is he going to work from home?
Yes.
No, he's working from the office.
For 1 to 9 P.m. Mohti. Okay. Did you confirm if the cab is available and all of that?
Yes.
Cab is available for 9 to 5, but yes, if we have to make changes for one or two day, that is something which is a little trickier because for one or two day, it is mostly not available at the same time.
So how can you help me to make sure that Murphy can cover that for 129?
So 1 to 9, okay, so the problem lies like 1 to 9, if it is starting of the week, he can do Monday and Tuesday. Now for Wednesday, again, if he comes in 9 to 5, that will be a little difficult.
Yeah, I remember that.
Yeah.
Is that any, maybe it's just Wednesday only? I know that would be hard for him, you know, like for that, but is that what about only Wednesday that would allow him to work from home for that time? That would be helpful or not?
We are already taking it to consideration. Amit sir, do you have anything to say on this?
Kip.
We certainly can try and see what alternatives. If it is for a day or two, then of course we'll figure this out, Neeraj. Right. We'll have to come back to you to see what solution works, but yeah, we will figure out something if it is just for a day or two.
Yes, mhm, I'll say it to you.
Okay.
Yeah, I think we need, we need, we need a flexibility with him or with anybody, you know, if they, because sometimes Neeraj has special requirements to have people changing shapes, so...
We're okay to work from home with the issues in the cap. You know, something to check with each other report. We need someone to call her. So if you can check on that, that would be great.
Yeah, just...
Yeah, so just that, you know, as an organization, we try to try to limit the work from home situations only if it is not an dear expectation. It is kind of a medical emergency that you can say, right? So if it is a medical emergency or something which is really, really urgent for people, that's when we go ahead and put
that those work from home exceptions, right? But we try to limit it as much as possible because, you know, we once we make start making exceptions, then people will start taking that for granted and we will start getting more requests. But having said this, like Negi just said that, you know, if there are requirements wherein we do not have caps available, we'll certainly try and do our best.
Yes.
to make sure that you have flexibility.
Well...
Okay, would ITBD allow them to submit an expense report for the cab if you can arrange them on their behalf?
In terms of cab availability, Jose, you're saying?
Right, so my understanding is that you scheduled the cap for them, but if the cap is not available at that time, can they just take a cab and submit an expense report to go to work from the office on that day? Then we need some flexibility sometimes. It's not all the time, but sometimes Nietzsche needs someone to cover that after hours. So it's cumbersome to us.
Yeah, so, yeah, so...
If we want to work with IT by design staff, we need to have that flexibility. Either they work from home or they get a cab arrangement or they submit an expense report for that tax that they take in order to, you know, comply with your policy.
Yeah, exactly. So this is what I was saying, Jose, that we've figured out ways, right, through which we allow people to do it. I mean, if it is for a day or two, it becomes more easy because you do not have to reimburse for the entire month, right? At times people are not really comfortable spending on caps for the entire month because of course they will have financial budgets and engineers do not have a very high salary, so they can.
But yeah, if it is for a day, two or three days, or even four, five days, it can be done. So leave it with us, Jose. I mean, it's something that we will fix it on our side. But yeah, if it is not a long-term arrangement, and if it is for, you know, last minute coverage that you need to support Neeraj, we will certainly do anything that is required on our side.
Thank you. Does that work each time?
Yes. Also, I want to explain a little bit. I get that like, you know, Charles will be out for two days, but it will be difficult, you know, for them to, you know, like get up to work on the next day in the early shift again. But I feel like in terms of the settings that I have to change,
Because we work on the appointments as well, right? So those appointments gotta be changed, you know, like at a certain time and all of that. And...
It's really difficult to work on the schedule. That's the reason why sometime, you know, the appointment has been made already. And then, you know, like when I change that schedule on the ticketing system, it's going to, you know, I have to, yeah, it's a little bit headache. That's the reason why I just feel like, you know, when they out one or two day, maybe just change for certain days only.
But if for the whole week, it's going to impact a whole lot of the schedules along with the team. So I try not to.
I think I just don't want to mess up, you know, like the appointments that are already booked, some of them. But I mean, just to, I have done a lot already rescheduling this and that manually. But if you have a better option, you know, I would like to hear from you guys as well. Because Chauhan will be out Monday and Tuesday. That's already difficult for the rest of the week.
And yeah, and I don't know if any better idea. That's why I just approached this way to just, you know, like have him working from home on the next day, maybe it would be helpful.
So your point is that Charles is going to be out Monday and Tuesday. He needs someone to take over that chief.
Yeah, so that shift is, if that shift, you know, like, I mean, Murphy got a shift, but the day after, Murphy had to get up early to work on the early shift. That's the reason why Excel mentioned about, like, how difficult it is for them, because they just rest for, you know, like some time, and they have to get up to just work on the next shift.
So.
So, Mohti is covering Monday and Tuesday from 1 to 9.
Correct.
Murphy. Yeah, I mean, for last time, Murphy covered that, right? So the whole week, I have Murphy covered the rest for one to 9, which is fine. But I have been working a lot, manually rescheduling, you know, and working on the boards and all of that. And the next week, I have to change it again because
because Murphy is back and then Pook and then Charles is back. And then again, Charles take him back to back, you know, for each week. So I have to change that setting for each week, which is a little bit, you know, like a lot for me. So that's why I'm asking for him, you know, like to cover to working from home maybe on Wednesday.
so he came back to his regular shift.
which is like help me save some time for the appointments and all of that. I don't know if I'm if you guys getting what I'm saying.
Yeah, I guess we get it. Uh, Neeraj, is that okay if me and Akhilesh can review and come back to you or what solution that we can bring?
Yeah, thank you.
Okay, okay, okay.
And on the similar line nature, I would also like to mention about the wedding leaves that Murphy will be taking in June. So there also we need to have a plan because then also we might have to go and work for the coverage.
Mhm.
Yes.
For Murphy, Murphy going to cover from 9 to 5, right? So from 9 to 5, we have enough, you know, like people to cover. That's the reason why it's not really, you know, like, I would say like urgent as child because child is 1 to 9 and they have only two agents after hours.
Okay.
But 9 to 5, I could find someone, you know, I myself, you know, like can have, I'll be very helping and I'm the one who like reading the board, something like that. So that's a backup plan, you know, from 9 to 5. But outside of 9 to 5, it would be difficult. Yeah. That's the reason why I moved Murphy back to 9 to 5 as well.
It's gonna be flexible for him, you know, to maybe cover later and also, like, or you know, the shift that would be like easier to plan.
Absolutely. And one more thing, I would like to bring it over here. So like Charles is doing that shift for a long time. And we know that whenever he's out, we have to just make adjustments and everything. And in case like later in the year, if he like feels like that he might be moving to the next shift or might be in the morning shift.
Do we or should we plan anything for that as well? Because we need to be proactive on that as well.
Yeah, remember he told us about this before and the way I try to respond on this one is about a ship rotation.
Mmh.
Uh-huh.
So I think we were talking with Anderson as well about the shift rotation maybe every like three months, four months, or six months. So we can talk about that later if you would like to, you know, like talk to me. I think I'm fine with that. Or Jose, do you have any comments about this?
Well, I just feel like, but the point is, what is the coverage? What is the alternative? You know, if Charles is moving, who is going to cover it? Is it Morphy? Is it going to be Paul Keith? You know, what is the what is the alternative that IT by design can offer to to make a change?
As long as you know.
Mm.
We have we have 3 shifts after hours, so it's 12 to 8, 1 to 9, and 8 to 4, so those are the.
The most challenging shifts.
Yes, right. That's why we can talk about it. I don't.
Do you have any idea, so we can see if it's possible to, you know, arrange that?
to see how we're going to rotate them for the after hours.
Yeah, absolutely. And I'm actually trying to figure out something because it is definitely something which we have to make sure that we have everything in place if something happens like that. Because, yeah, that needs to be there. I'll talk to Amit and we'll talk.
Good.
No.
Yes.
Thank you.
definitely craft a plan for that.
Mick.
Yeah, that would be great. Thank you. Because cap arrangement is also, you know, like another factor that we have to think about.
Yeah.
Yeah, yep, yep, yep.
Mick.
Okay, thank you, yep.
So let me share the topics here.
Alright, and.
I think that's one is a big one, and...
Okay, I think I'm going to jump to the KPI. Oh, I want to update about the chat support. So recently, I don't know if you heard from them about the chat, you know, access issues on AVD. So the chat, you know, like access required a tap.
or like a one-time passcode for them. Because what we use here, we use a single sign-on. And, you know, since it's on the AVD, the single sign-on doesn't work. And they have to use, you know, that, you know, like tap for multi-factor authentication. And somehow it was, you know, like being on and off.
Mhm.
So, now Jason disabled the tab, and right now they, you know, logging into the desktop app without a tab, which is, you know, like I think it's fine, as long as you know, like Jason agree with that, or maybe you can ask some about this updates, and right now I also tested with them, it's working fine with.
The app, the desktop app, just in case if you, you know, like heard from Cool Gate or Murphy about chat issues or something, feel free to let me know or check with.
I mean, just in case, because right now they have the chat, you know, the support assigned to them both to cover after hours. Yeah, so during the day, we also have another one staff, you know, like helping, so to cover from 8, you know, like to 9 P.m. the whole, you know, like service hours, yeah.
Uh-huh.
So I think what we're saying is that we had some issues with the chat feature and that has been resolved because Jason from us, our centralized services team disabled that temporary access passcode that they needed. They don't get the passcode. The passcode had to be...
Keep him by Jason, and if Jason is not working because it's after hours, then they don't have it, and then they can't log in if the issue is resolved, but if you heard something, if you hear something happening again, lend each other right away, or the team can lend each other also.
Yeah.
Uh, but it should be fixed by now, so...
Yes.
Sure, I haven't heard anything from them from the last call that we had, but yes, I'll definitely make sure that it's communicated to you if it comes.
Thank you.
Thank you. And, oh, for the training for Poolgit, the customer service training, remember? The one that we try to have the same as HDI. Have you been planning for that or how it's going?
Mhm.
Yeah, so we discussed about it and it is the time when we are going for that of one full day. That would be where we have the company holiday from community ID as well. So yeah, that is what we have agreed upon and I'm in talk with our L&D team for that.
Oh.
What is that?
Okay, what day is it?
I think the recent upcoming one is the 27th of May, I believe.
Oh, US holiday, right?
Yep, US holiday.
7th of May.
27th.
Oh, 27. OK.
That is in Memorial Day, I believe.
27th of May? No, that's not Memorial Day.
27th or let me see, it was 25th of May, yeah.
25th.
Yeah.
Sorry, I'm checking now.
25th.
Yep.
Okay.
Yes.
Yeah, so it's Memorial Day, okay.
Mhm.
All right, perfect.
Um...
Yeah, I think that's...
That's all for the priorities ones, and I'm going to go for each KPI.
And where we are on this topic, Neeraj. So for Charles, as he, you know, that he has upgraded himself and also just trying to brush up his skills, do we have anything which he can work on apart from the one to be used that he is taking care of as of now?
Go.
So any advanced work he can get into it.
Hmm.
Um...
Well, Sash has, because we have, we have, we have protocols from the Helpdesk, so there are certain tickets that don't go to the Helpdesk by nature, so I don't know specifically what are you asking for, like, what, what are you suggesting for some?
So I'm suggesting like he has completed his advanced system administrator, the role and the requirement that an advanced engineer should have. So advanced troubleshooting, anything with an escalation, which can become an escalation for another engineer.
And.
that he can take care or anything that you have in mind which he can work on. But he is just seeing himself as an engineer who is working on the advanced tickets.
Okay.
So just to add one more thing, Jose, and thank you for bringing this up, Akhilesh. So what, Jose, what happens is, right, every engineer, they would have a tech level, right? And when they get the promotion to the next tech level, like Akhilesh explained,
Mhm.
they are expected to have additional skill set which they did not have in the beginning. So in case of Charles, what we are speaking about, now that he is advanced system administrator, which means that at his level now, he is capable of working on wider technologies, he can work on escalated tickets as well.
he moves up in terms of getting more exposure. But he has been assessed, interviewed, and he has gone through a systematic process wherein he has qualified himself by clearing the interview to be called as a advanced system administrator, which we call them as an L2, right?
which means that his level.
of expertise and competency is higher than what he was earlier. So what help that we need, right, from yourself and Nicha would be that what we can do, we can send you over an email the skill set that he previously had and what additional expertise that he currently has, right?
Could be even if it is a O365, he is more advanced in O365, just for an example. But what we can help you with is giving you a very clear understanding of what additional skill set now he brings on table for you, right? And he will be more inclined towards working those as well, so that he is properly utilizing his skill set.
And so that you are able to review and let us know right if you are able to get him some work which aligns with the skill set, or if you have a roadblocker there, but in terms of his career progression, every engineer goes through a similar kind of skill enhancement to make sure they are moving up the ladder.
Just not in terms of tenure, also in terms of the skill set. Does it give you a clear understanding, Jose?
That makes sense.
Yeah, yeah, just send me that email then I'll review it.
Yeah.
Sure, yeah, that'll be really, really helpful. Thank you. And it's good news for you, Jose and Nicha, because you know, you have in your existing engineer who's more capable now, so you can certainly go ahead and utilize him even better.
Thank you.
Definitely, yes.
Uh-huh.
Um...
The CSAT is good. Answer it is good. I also, you know, like, I think because Charles get used to it already to keep an eye on Five Nine, I mean, yeah, on Five Nine State doesn't all of that. But the concern is about the utilization number that I'm also trying to work on with him.
Kip.
Because he's more comfortable with EC issues and all of that, you know, I just want to make sure we're not under billing. So if you want to check with him as well, just in case, you know, to see like if he has, I think the amount of the ticket that he.
Close, I think it's pretty, you know, like average, so it could be. I also like trying to work it on myself as well with the timesheet and all of that, but in case if you, you know, want to talk to him about like how he utilize the time, you know, on the on the tickets or is that the time we build that's you know appropriate and all that, that would be helpful.
Is this Charles?
Charles Yu.
You say that he's more comfortable with easy tickets?
So yeah, and that was my point as well. So I actually review his billables and everything and he says, I do not take that much of time, so I'm not able to bill it. Like if I'm just spending 10 minutes, I can only put in like more than.
Oh yeah, because he, you know...
just two or three more minutes, so 12 or 13 or 15, because I don't take that much of time in those tickets. So that was the other reason as well why I was asking for advanced and complex tickets, because the tickets that he was doing earlier, he takes less time now to resolve them.
Yeah, and that makes sense. But I wonder what is that coming from Nicha? You say that he is more comfortable with easier tickets. Is that that he's more comfortable taking easier tickets or that his tickets feel like it's easier to resolve? I'm not sure if I understood.
To comment correctly.
No, no, no, I'm sorry. Yeah, I'm sorry. Maybe I put in the wrong word. What I'm saying is just like, you know, when he work on easy tickets, that's the reason why, you know, like utilization time that he doesn't really spend a lot on easy tickets or service requests. Yeah, so he like, yeah, it took him pretty like fast to complete it.
Okay.
So in other words, it's taking him less time to complete search or service request, which is reflected on his long utilization because it's been faster.
Yes.
Yeah.
And that is that that makes sense that that that that aligns with what Akhilesh and Amit has mentioned that he has new skills built in built up and now it's his faster, so that I think that's fine. His utilization is slow because of that. That's a good.
Thank you.
That's a good thing, actually.
Yeah, yeah, so I just, you know, just ask Akhilesh to just double check, just in case, you know, like, if there is, yeah, anything.
Absolutely.
What is your concern? Your concern is that he's not billing accurately?
Some of them, it's just because of, like, I cannot assume, like, when the note is short, right? I just, I just can't really assume is that really time or the note is long, is that actual time he spent, you know? So, just ask, you know, Excel to help me, you know, like to check with him from time to time, like, if the billing, you know, accurately.
Mhm.
And that's all only the point because I have been working a lot in April. We're going to see a different number in April that I can't wait to see. So let's see, you know, I think I'm also like helping, you know, like him to work on this as well, because I also remind him about some, you know, like the cancellation and I mean the ticket.
the appointment when it's canceled. Or cancel appointment or like no answer on the appointment. So we also build the time. Just keep reminding him on that as well. Yeah.
Okay, so it's when you're approving timesheets and then you see long resolution nodes, you're checking with him, right? Say, hey, is this accurate? Okay, and if he says yes, I think that's fine. That is just a sign of the same thing. He's just faster.
Yes.
Yeah.
Right. So I would not. I would not worry too much about that because it sounds like he has a lot of time. He has been working with us for a long time. He has built a good set of skills and he's confirming with you that he's faster. So that's expected with someone gets a lot of experience.
Thank you.
You see, it's working faster, so it's really on us to utilize him better, utilize his time better to put it in the right way. So, this is, well, we don't have escalations. Well, do you do have escalations metrics per agent? I'm assuming his escalation is low.
Is this condition right, right?
Yes.
Do you remember what is the number for that?
Oh, I don't remember.
Might be worth a check.
I can be.
But yeah, but I check it like regularly with him about his escalated tickets and everything. So I do not find like a lot of tickets going out. So he's doing it by himself.
Okay, good, good. That's great to hear.
Yeah.
Ohh.
I think we should pack up this with the escalation rate for him as well. Like, you're gonna send me an email on this, so that's good. We can see the scales built. We can see.
Yeah.
What is the amount of tickets that he's closing percentage-wise compared to the rest of the team? Do you know Nicha?
Let me pull that up.
Yeah, he has, so for the month of March, 17% of the tickets.
Did work on 17%, which is good, and that's above average.
Yeah, that, yeah, but.
So he has a good amount of tickets that he's resolving.
Abe.
Yeah, I just want to see an overall picture of his metrics, of his performances, to back up all this idea of, you know, maybe it's time for him to...
And.
Thanks.
Move up or finding other things that he could do.
We need to document this properly, but I hear you.
Yeah, so he also excited about, like, in April, he said I only share, I have seen my billable time different this month, I think, because of like the refresher training I just provided to the team, also helpful, you know, for them to, you know, align with, which is good. So, I'm going to, I mean, I work with him closely as well, because he's working from after. I just want to make sure everything's set before I leave.
Kour.
Okay.
that. But yeah, I would say like, you know, it's a good time, you know, for us to to look into that. And I think that's all I have for Charles because he has been fantastic, you know, and I heard you about the ship rotation, you know, and he told me the same, but I don't really have any plan yet.
So that's why I say, like, I should talk to you first, Excel, and let's see how possible that could be. And then after that, we can, you know, like, I can also, you know, share with Jonsanto with that plan as well and see if it's possible. Next is about, if it's no questions about Charles, I'm going to move to.
Sure.
No, I'm good. I said it all.
Mick.
Haha, OK.
So, for Murphy as well, I think Murphy has been very, you know, like...
very reliable. And Murphy also helped me a lot with, you know, like with so many things, you know, like he's willing to change this and that as well. And I also worked with him recently about the, what's that called?
the ticket, it's like a DMARC ticket. So he also like, you know, share a very good point. I just want to, you know, kudos him for that for, you know, like the proactive ones that he always shared a feedback to me. And the answer rates, you know, like from his KPI has been improved, you know, like for March.
Yeah.
I think he have done a lot better. And the same day resolution also, you know, like getting closer to the goal, which is good. I think he escalate less ticket and he also challenged himself a lot too. I think probably because he worked on the certification, that's the reason why, you know, like he maybe want to.
just use some of that tips as well. And the utilization number is also like I have seen a lot, you know, in April and I think it's going to be a big adjustment as well because sometimes he work, it seems so long that he work with them, but he builds, he seems to build less, so that's why I just asked him to double check.
But some of them, you know, like it's accurate, some of them not, but we're working on that. So I'm not really like concerned about his utilization. And also confirm a lot with the cancel appointment or last minute, you know, like, or no answer, you know, like appointment. So we talk about that.
And it's good. So far so good, but he sees that it's 100%, you know, like straight from January, that I'm very happy same as Charles as well. And I know that you just mentioned about his AZ900 certification. I think he's taking a pause because he's doing that reading preparation and all of that, right?
Ohh.
Kip.
Yep.
So, do you think you're gonna receive him again by June or when?
Yes, by June, by June. Once he is back from his wedding, he straight away is going to deep dive into it.
OK, so I will, yeah, so please, you know, keep me posted for that, and...
Sure.
Okay.
Any questions about Murphy?
Dope.
OK, that's good.
And just one on the Fiveline side. So have you seen some changes over there now? Because we have discussed a lot of our tip with them.
Yeah.
Oh yeah, yeah, yeah, I have seen that. I have seen, I also like carry five with the team as well, you know, about when you, how you gonna check the campaign inbound call, this and that, just to make sure that you know they use the status correctly and the wrap up time, it's you know, like, you know, like put it up correctly.
Hello?
Mmh.
After, you know, they hang up the call, they have two minutes for a wrap up. You know, one of us was, didn't really, I don't know, maybe they see like, you know, like accidentally with the drop down with the campaign. So when they see like with the wrong campaign, the wrap up time also changed. So I want to make sure, I already, you know, like...
Talk to them about that, just to make sure they all know, like, how does this supposed to look like, so the rep time gonna work properly, so they have more time, you know, available on calls as well, and if they're not available, you know, like, make sure they change the status accurately. It's also like that's easy for me to spot who is on break.
who is not. If they're working online and then what tickets they're working on, I also keep an eye on all of those. Which is like working good so far. And thank you, you know, for pushing that. I think I'm going to, you know, check on that for one more month and then we can close this loop. Okay?
Sure.
Sure, perfect.
I actually had, I wanna say kudos to you and to them, of course, our answer rate in March was amazing, and same for February, so we just wanna make sure that we keep it up, and as Aneja mentioned, this has to do with the...
Rick.
Yes.
Yeah.
a healthy and proper utilization of our codes in Five Nine. If they're ready, they should be ready. If they're not ready, then their status should not be ready, and they should be ready when they should be ready. So making sure that they use those statuses properly is what actually helps guarantee.
Sure.
Yeah.
this answer rate. And for the last two months, it's been fantastic. 95% of answer rate. And I think in less than two minutes, it was like...
Mm.
90 something and 95.
Yeah, 93, 95.
Right, Lisa? Yeah.
For Murphy, yes, 95.
Yes.
Yeah, so that's fantastic.
Yeah.
I have a request, Jose. We have a state of the department meeting that happens every Monday. If you think it is worth recognizing these guys, giving a shout out in front of the entire team, if you could drop an email to me and Akhilesh as a token of decision to them, we'll make sure that.
We're calling out their name for the amazing contribution. And of course, letting them know how appreciative you are for the contribution, you and Neeraj.
Sure.
Okay.
Yeah, you can go ahead. I mean, you can let them know that we recognize that sounds all right, feel free. I mean, I don't know if you need anything else from me, but...
Send an email, Ray.
Yep.
Send email.
Yeah, if you can. Yep, yep, that'll be great.
Yeah.
Nikki, can you point out those metrics to them in an email? Yeah, OK.
No.
Yeah.
Yeah, sure, sure, sure. Yeah, I will, and thank you. And also, on top of that, I'm cleaning up with the with their calendars as well, you know, just to make sure I'm trying to push that utilization number, you know, we're working on that point, so...
Just want to make sure that something, I have changed so many settings and then maybe something is not really on them, but maybe on the settings that I really have to understand it through. So I'm working on that. Hopefully, you know, we're going to utilize the time better during their shift. Yeah, and that's all for Murphy. If you have no questions, I'm going to move forward to PooGet.
Oh, who's into?
Yeah.
Um, Neeraj, um, I think it was Morphy who had a break, uh, scheduled on his calendar.
Big.
It's not him. Yeah, but it's not him. It's not really about the Outlook. I already checked. It's more about the setting on the connect-wise that I'm working on. I'm also new with this setting, so I'm trying to understand how this, you know, like setting has been duplicated from the connect-wise setting. Yeah, it's not on their calendar.
Yeah, I will go back to you about this on the interview because I need to understand better as well how does it work, you know, with this schedule.
But I already identified the problem is not really on the outlook. Yeah, I think it's the same with Kaila as well. So I'm going to work on these issues. Hopefully we're going to figure it out soon.
If this green, if this green is coming from their outlook.
Yeah, but yeah, we checked, but he's not really on his Outlook.
So.
So, I don't know if it's the Singh problem.
But I don't see it anymore.
Ohh.
So, sorry here, Mohti.
Yeah.
I don't, I don't see it on Morphe. I just see it on Kaila, so, but that's another.
Yeah, because maybe I fixed that yesterday for Murphy, but I will look into Kaila soon, yeah.
Okay, sounds good.
Yeah, so for Phuket, I think...
I feel bad for him a little bit because so many things change, you know, in between, but he's 30, he's 90 days, you know, like coming up. So I'm going to prepare for that as well. And also he has been working a lot on tickets and calls. I think it's pretty good, but I'm still like trying to, you know, like,
Oh.
monitors, you know, like his notes or some of his tickets as well. It just, just to make sure he, you know, like he know how to navigate the tickets. Sometime, you know, like I understand that he's, he's.
Mhm.
Quite confidence, per his, you know, like experience, which is like, which is different from our clients. Maybe he assumed too soon, you know, for the resolution or something. So, what I need your help, it's not really a big issue or anything, it's just a small touch. I need your help that to just, you know, like...
Check with him from time to time with the with the ticket, like like a spam ticket. Sometime you know it's need more time to analyze with something, you know, with that, so ask if he has any question or if he needs help with that, but I, I, I share him some feedback already, you know, just to...
let just to show him how does it work, how to shake the email headers, or how do we analyze this type of ticket. But yeah, I want you to, you know, to follow up with him for that, just to build up his confidence and just to, you know, like expose him for more, you know, like tools that we can use.
But like I say, it's not really a particular concern. It's just about what I can see. Maybe, you know, like he might not ask me, but so far so good overall. And let's jump to his KPI. His KPI is good with answer rate, I think, because I worked on.
Everybody's, you know, like answer it as well, so he also helped me with that and set the resolution. I think he worked on so many service requests and he sent the solution number is pretty good, as well as the utilization number, because he worked along with those tickets he closed and like the first time, 100% he said, you know.
Yeah.
positive score, which is like great. And I, you know, I would say like, thank you so much, you know, for your push as well. And I know that, you know, Pugit has been, I would say like strict changing, you know, along with my plan for this, you know, like coverage as well. But it's good. I'm very happy that Pugit's, you know, like,
ask me so many questions, which is good, which is I expect. I also, I also curious that if he asks you any things, you know, like, or check with you regularly.
I go to him regularly, so I, before he comes to me, I go to him.
Yeah.
Okay, yeah, yeah, that's good.
And I've told him to bug you as well.
Yes, yes. Because, you know, sometimes when they're new, they may not know what to ask or where to ask or something. Yeah.
Yeah.
Absolutely.
So for anything which is process related, I had told him clearly that Neeraj would be available for you in case if you have process related anything. And in case if it is technical, definitely you can come back to me.
Yeah, yeah, thank you. I think those things he asked me right away, or I also remind him right away, because I know that he's new. Even though he's, I already trained him that, but just because he's new, he's not, you know, familiar with the processes. So I just asked him to check the document again and again.
just to remind him where to find it, this and that, which is good. And after hours, you know, like I also sound check with him. I heard that he got a drive for so far, but I don't know if he has any problem with that.
No, I think he drives his own. So yeah, that is not a problem as of now. Yeah.
Okay, so it's not kept required for him.
Ohh.
Okay, perfect. Yeah, so it's good. And do you have any like shadowy sessions, you know, like for him?
For shadowing session, yes, I would like to just know that you have definitely given me one of the aspects, which is the spam filtering and everything. Do you see any other areas where I can just help him out? Because I have a lot of engineers working on these technologies. So we can align.
Yeah.
Yeah, I can send you the ticket number just in case, you know, like just for, just for you, you know, to, it doesn't mean he didn't do, he did something wrong, but I'm just saying like maybe it's something that we could, you know, like do better for that approach.
Mmh.
Absolutely, absolutely. That is the continuous improvement that we want to see and we can definitely put it across it like that. Yeah.
What?
OK, let me put the note here.
Yeah.
Hey.
And monitor setup. Okay, so she has two monitors. Oh, I don't know how many, okay. So that's good. Because at first he didn't really have two monitors, so.
Yeah.
So, the standard over here in ITBD is 1 monitor, so for partners who require whose requirement is there, so we put it across it like that.
Okay, so he has two monitors now, right? Yeah, and did you remind him about like 59? You know, like Tuesday sign in only one screen. Okay, this.
Yeah, yeah.
Absolutely. That is for all the three engineers to have one of the screen dedicated to 59.
Perfect. Thank you.
Okay.
Um...
And I think the training, I mean for new stop training is completed and it's just the 90 days that coming up, that's on the list that I have.
Uh-huh.
So it's.
February, March, April. Yeah, I think probably like by end of April. I'm not sure with the date, but yeah, I will prepare that 90 days performance review because we have to review based on this KPI as well. And also, you know, like just remind him as well about.
On the paper.
Mmh.
That's 90 days performance review is coming up, so he gonna have that once, you know, one-on-one session with me to go through that performance review, and I will, I will have, I still have weekly check-in with him, just, you know, like to open some time for him to ask me any questions.
Even sometimes we don't even need the full hour, you know, like to finish that weekly check-in because we also have monthly check-in to go through the KPI. But I still have, you know, like to go back and work with him on a few topics. But other than that, you know, like I think it's in progress. Yeah, it's good progress so far.
Maybe it's time to make it half an hour.
Perfect.
For weekly check-in, yes.
Yeah, if you're not taking the whole hour, just make it half an hour now, so that way his calendar is more available for a format that you don't have to like commit for a whole hour.
Hello.
Mhm.
Yeah, yeah, sometime, yeah, sometime. Yeah, I think it's also like I might cancel that soon too because it's pretty good. Yeah, I think it has been a month already for the weekly check-in. I think it seems to be set. Yeah, so.
Tim, he's very fantastic.
Okay.
Yeah, or every two weeks maybe or something like that. It's up to you.
Yeah, maybe, yeah. Let's see if he need that. Oh, otherwise he can, you know, like he always just asks me if he can, you know, like have a minute or something. So I like that when they just address the issues right away with me, which is which is like is easier and they learn right away, which is good.
And also they address, you know, like the problem right away and they fix it. You know, everything is safe time for later. So I like that too. So that's why I try to keep the time available for them. And the AC104, you're going to follow up with that. Hopefully we're going to hear something and hopefully we can retrieve that certification.
Yeah.
If it's not, maybe you would have to talk to him about it and think about like what certification he feel like he lagging off. I don't know, maybe it's another MS 900 that he feel like he want to work on or how confident he is, you know, with the Azure or with Microsoft admin. So.
Mhm.
Yeah, just check with him just to see like if there's anything else. Because, yeah, I just want to hear more from him because right now I think he's focused a lot, you know, like on the tickets and all of that. I understand, but I also want to think about, you know, certification that's coming up for him as well.
Absolutely.
Yeah.
Sure, sure.
Yeah, so I think that's all I have for...
I'll pull it, unless Joseinio want to add something.
I'm good.
Thank you, Aneja, thank you, Aamir and Akhilesh.
Oh, alright.
Perfect, I've got my list of to-dos as well for the next action tracker and I'll send you the information 1 by 1 for all the open items that I have as of now. And the last thing that I want to discuss, so Neeraj, Jose, and I'm not sure if Saba is not there, but yes.
Yes.
We have build it coming. So what are your plans for this year?
We'll get back to you then.
I thought I was seeing, I thought I was seeing, and Sameer as always.
With.
Yeah.
I will confirm.
Yeah, that, yeah, okay. We'll send you, we'll send you the details, Jose, the scanner and everything through which you can find out more about it, and do let us know if there is anything at all needed. We will make sure that you have that information before time.
From later, we're working on that.
Sounds good. Thank you. Thank you both. Have a nice day.
Okay, cool. Yes.
Perfect. Thank you, Jose. Thank you, Chair. Bye. Take care.
Thank you. Thank you. Have a nice day. Bye.
All right, thank you, Aneja. Cheers, bye.